yesterday the Ohio State Buckeyes  defeated orienteer to win the college  football playoff championship now  afterwards students at Ohio State poured  into the streets in what some called a  victory riot check this out  [Applause]  okay I don't know if you've noticed but  most the rioters were white and they're  rioting about good news now this is  nothing unusual white people have  battled police over happy news for years  for example here's white people rioting  when Apple came out with the iPhone 6  yeah  here's white people rioting when Colin  Firth won the Best Actor Oscar for the  King's Speech they went nuts and white  people rioting when NBC announced that  parks and recreation was coming back  [Applause]  you